so the symbol I'm gonna talk about is
gamma little gamma which gets used for
lots of different things but in this
particular context I'm going to talk
about it it's use in special relativity
relativity is something that everyone is
actually familiar with it's the fact
that the laws of physics are kind of the
same in whatever reference frame you're
in so for example when you're sitting on
an aeroplane unless you look out of the
window you're really not aware of the
fact that you're traveling from one of
five hundred miles an hour that if you
were to you know sitting there at your
table to throw something up in the
arable rocking yo it will just fall back
down again and so on the laws of physics
are basically the same even though
you're moving relative to the earth or
high-speed and what special relativity
says is that all the laws of physics are
basically the same in any reference
frame that's moving at constant speed
and when you work through the mass of
all that and what that actually implies
one of the quantities that sort of comes
out all over the place is this the same
mathematical expression comes out all
over the place which is 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared where V is the speed at which
the reference frame is moving and sees
the speed of light and this comes up so
often that it's actually given its own
symbol it's called gamma it is a it's a
symbol that occurs all over the place in
special relativity for example one of
the places it occurs most blatantly is a
thing called time dilation which is that
if you're in a reference frame which
moving along at speed V it turns out
that your clocks move more slowly than
things that are stationary relative to
you so in fact if you were to just watch
the speed at which a time was ticking
away on a clock in something that's
moving like a rocket moving at some
velocity V it actually moves more slowly
than the clocks that are stationary and
the factor by which it moves more slowly
is 1 over gamma and so for example if
you put the numbers in for something
traveling at 90 percent of the speed of
light when you plug them into that
formula for gamma gamma comes out at
about 2 but over 2 and so that means
that something moving at 90 percent of
the speed of light the clocks there will
be traveling at about a factor of 2
slower than those that are say to me
this sounds very bizarre right because
people are used to the idea that clocks
are just clocks sometimes live as long
as they're behaving themselves they
should all tick at 1 second per second
and this idea that the rate at which
time progresses depends on what
reference frame Meereenese is pretty
bizarre but there's very strong
experimental evidence that it actually
really works one of the simplest
experiments
it turns out that there are particles
crashing into the Earth's atmosphere
crashing into the top of the Earth's
atmosphere sort of 40 or 50 kilometers
up and when they crash into the Earth's
atmosphere these cosmic rays smashing
into the atmosphere turn into muons you
create muons now turns out muons as a
particle have very short lifetime so
elementary particle that decays very
quickly and so they don't actually in
the time between them being created they
actually would decay before they get to
the ground even traveling at close to
the speed of light they don't have time
to get to ground level and so in the
absence of special relativity you would
predict that you should never detect any
of these muons if you have a muon
detector on the ground because although
they're being created up there they
don't actually have time to travel all
the way to the ground but because
they're traveling at close to the speed
of light that means that their internal
clocks are going slower and when your
clocks are going slower everything goes
slower including this process of
radioactive decay that these particles
actually decay more slowly than they
would do if they were just sitting
stationary in the lab which means they
actually do have time to get all the way
from where they're created tens of
kilometers up down to ground level so if
you have a muon detector in the lab you
can actually detect these cosmic ray
muons even though in the absence of
special relativity none of them should
ever have made it all the way from the
top of the atmosphere to the moon and
nine we have ignition sequence so
there's probably the most famous story
of this associated with this effect of
time dilation is this thing called the
twins paradox which is that if you were
you start with a pair of identical twins
and you send one of them off on a rocket
ship to Alpha Centauri and they go off
at some fraction of a height you know
high fraction of the speed of light so
they kept traveling sufficiently close
to the speed of light you have to worry
about these things the one who travels
away and goes off to Alice and Tori and
then comes back again because they're
moving the person so who stays at home
would see this person's clock traveling
more slowly and so therefore by the time
the twin who's gone to Alpha Centauri
and then come back again gets back again
they'll actually be younger than the
twin who stayed at home now the reason
why this is a paradox is because
everything is relative which means now
let's look at it from the twins point of
view who's on the rocket from the twins
point of view who's on the rocket he
just stayed in the rocket the entire
time and from his perspective the earth
shot off in the opposite direction for a
while and then when he turned around the
earth shot back again so from his
perspective he just stayed stationary
and the other twin the one who stayed on
earth did all the moving moved backwards
and came back again and so by exactly
the same
the between who'd actually gone all the
way to Alpha Centauri and back again
would argue actually I've seen my twin
doing traveling at high speed so I would
see my twins clocks traveling more
slowly and therefore my twins should be
younger than me so they you end up with
his paradox that each of them by this
argument of special relativity will
claim that they should then be younger
than their twin and the resolution to
this paradox is because the reasons
actually asymmetry in this situation
which is because the twin who actually
did the journey at some point had to
turn around and come back and that means
that the twin who did the journey didn't
stay in the same reference frame the
whole time he was initially in one
reference frame traveling one way and
then later on was in another reference
frame traveling the other way which
means at some point he must have
accelerated decelerating to a stop and
then accelerated back the other way and
as soon as you introduce acceleration
into the mix of things that special
relativity doesn't work anymore and if
you really want to resolve this put in
paradox properly you have to consider
general relativity which is the version
of relativity you have to use as soon as
you have accelerations so the one who
would end up being younger is actually
the one who went to Alpha Centauri
impact but the ultimate resolution when
you do the job properly